كيف تتم عمليه التصويت في الانتخابات
التركيه في المناطق التي ضربها زلزال
كهرمان مرش في السادس من شباط الماضي نحن
الان في محافظه كهرمان مرش وتشاهدون خلفي
بيوتا مسبقه الصنع وضعتها اللجنه العليا
للانتخابات في ساحات المدارس وفي الحدائق
حتى يتمكن المواطنون هنا من الادلاء
باصواتهم كذلك وضعت خياما فيها صناديق
الاقتراع في المخيمات الموجوده في المناطق
الريفيه من المحافظات المتضرره كما سمحت
للنازحين الى الولايات الاخرى ان يدلو
باصواتهم في المناطق التي نزحوا اليها بعد
تغيير عناوينهم الحجم الانتخابي لهذه
المحافظات المتضرره من الزلزال كبير هنالك
نحو تسعه ملايين ناخر تعتبر معظم
المحافظات التركيه المتضرره من الزلزال
جنوبيه تركيا من المعاقل التقليديه لتحالف
الجمهور الحاكم صوتت في انتخابات عام 2018
عشره من اصل 11 محافظه متضرره من الزلزال
لصالح الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان فهل
سوف يكون هنالك تاثير لكارسه الزلزال على
نتائج الانتخابات التركيه ام ان حزب
العداله والتنميه وتحالف الجمهور الحاكم
سوف يتمكن من المحافظه على الاصوات
التقليديه لناخذه في هذه المناطق